اعلنت جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين عبر قناه
المسيره التابعه لها ان غارات امريكيه
وبريطانيه استهدفت فجر اليوم منطقه راس
عيسه في محافظه الحديده غرب
اليمن ومن الحديده ينضم الان الينا
مراسلنا سمير النمري اهلا بك سمير اذا
ضعنا في تفاصيل في صوره تفاصيل هذا الخبر
تفضل نعم ليلى بحسب مصادر فقد شن الطيران
الامريكي والبريطاني عدوانا جديدا فجر
اليوم على منطقه راس عيسى بحسب المصدر فان
الاستهداف تم على معسكر مخلى من الجنود
وان هذا المعسكر قد تعرض لضربات في السابق
مقللا من اي تاثير لهذه الضربات على القوى
العسكريه لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين هذه
الضربه تاتي فقط بعد بعد ساعات من قيام
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين باستهداف سفينه
نفطيه بريطانيه كانت تبحر في خليج عدن
وانه بحسب الناطق العسكري لانصار الله فقد
احترقت هذه السفينه عندما استهدفت بصواريخ
بالستيه بحريه بحسب المصدر عسكري ايضا في
انصار الله فقد تم استهداف مؤخره السفينه
بشكل متعمد حتى كما قال لا لا يتم اصابه
طاقم السفينه هذه السفينه ما زالت بحسب
المصادر تحترق حتى هذه اللحظه وان هناك
جهود لعمليه
اطفائها ما يثير الانتباه ليلى بان هذا
الاستهداف للسفينه البريطانيه تم لاول مره
في خليج عدن وهي مناطق تبعد نسبيا عن
مناطق سيطره انصار الله الحوثيين هنا مثلا
في مدينه الحديده تبعد منطقه الاستهداف
بنحو 400 100 كيل مر وقد تم استهدافها
بصواريخ بالستيه بعيده المدى هذا التطور
كان ياتي بعد تحذيرات اصدرتها قياده
الجماعه وقائد انصار الله بان الاستهداف
او الرد على العدوان الامريكي البريطاني
بحسب وصفه ات لا محاله وان هذا الاستهداف
تم بعد ايام فقط من استهداف سفينه امريكيه
تجاريه كانت ايضا موجوده في خليج عدن رغم
النفي الامريكي كان الناطق العسكري باسم
انصار الله قد قال انه قبل يومين حدث
اشتباك مع مدمرات وبوارج وسفن امريكيه في
منطقه باب المندب وخليج عدن وانه تم اصابه
احدى السفن العسكريه الامريكيه اشكرك سمير
النمري من الحديده على كل هذه المعلومات